y
y nadie nace inteligente todos empezamos
desde cero no podemos caminar no podemos
hablar
definitivamente no sabemos álgebra sumar
restar leer escribir andar en bicicleta
nadie es bueno en nada al principio
einstein no sabía contar hasta 10 y
shakespeare tuvo que aprender el
abecedario igual que todos nosotros
afortunadamente nacimos para aprender
despacio te tropiezas deslizas caes
fallas las balas te equivocas frustrado
confundido intentando luchando hasta que
un día
caminas un pie delante del otro una idea
que va más allá que la anterior cada
respuesta incorrecta fortaleciendo tu
cerebro no equivocarse es sólo otra
forma de decir crecer pero
y sigues adelante esto es emprender
saber que lo entenderás aún cuando no lo
comprendes todavía porque los conceptos
más hermosos y complejos están
construidos sobre ideas básicas que
todos pueden entender quien quiera que
seas donde sea que usted es lo único que
necesitas saber es que tú puedes
aprender cualquier cosa